what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and the kenobi series is
off to a phenomenal start i really
really enjoyed the first three episodes
and i really enjoyed episode three we
got vader versus kenobi now granted it
wasn't a kenobi at full strength that
might actually be why vader decided not
to kill obi-wan in that moment but
that's the scene we're going to be
talking about today we saw vader torture
obi-wan kenobi in episode three he
literally used the force to control his
body and drag him through flames now at
the end why didn't vader finish the job
why didn't vader put the fire out with
the force like he previously did minutes
before
that's the question that we're going to
address today and i have three possible
explanations of why vader decided not to
kill obi-wan at that moment and they all
could actually be true simultaneously so
if you're into star wars be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest star wars videos i'll be
doing a lot more so the first one seems
to be the most just blatantly obvious
reason of why vader decided not to kill
obi-wan kenobi in that moment and that
is because
he was just toying with him
vader can realize and has realized that
obi-wan kenobi is now terrified of him
and that's what the first couple of
episodes set up as well as episode three
as well we can see that obi-wan kenobi
is haunted he is haunted by the past of
anakin skywalker and now darth vader and
he didn't know that he was alive but now
he does so obi-wan kenobi spent the last
10 years thinking about his young
padawan the person that he trained and
thinking about how he turned to the dark
side he is a sith lord now
how did that happen he has to be going
through his thoughts going what could i
have done differently
to possibly prevented this and kept
anakin on the right side of the force
right on the light side being a jedi
plus anakin was supposed to be the
chosen one that's gotta eat at him as
well that's really gotta eat at him but
vader knows all of this and vader can
see that obi-wan kenobi this is not the
same obi-wan this is not the jedi master
obi-wan kenobi this is a kenobi who has
not really done anything relating to
being a jedi in 10 years and he's not
weak like darth vader actually says
during the episode and vader just tosses
him around like he's nothing and now
vader knows that he could beat him very
very easily but like he said he wants to
torture him and he actually said it in
the episode he said this is just the
beginning this is just the start of his
torture he wants to get back at him so
using the force to bring him into the
flames that was that was pretty intense
that was pretty intense and that's just
the start well the way i see it is vader
let him go yes vader could have used the
force to remove the fire we saw him do
that yes vader could have used the force
to simply grab him we just watched him
walk through
a street right
and just snap in younglings next that
hasn't changed yet has his cheese from
order 66 to this i mean jeez yeah and
just controlling people dragging them
down the street using the force just to
do whatever he wants of course he could
have grabbed obi-wan of course he could
have grabbed tal he could have done
whatever he wanted to he let him get
away on purpose why
to torture him some more in his mind
mentally he's living rent free in his
head right now obi-wan is scared and he
knows vader's going to be coming for him
so
yeah vader really really wants to
torture him he's not going to do it just
physically of course that's part of his
plan but he's going to do it mentally
too and i think this was a part of that
mental torture plan now the second
reason a reason that i actually really
really like of why vader let him live is
because vader wants to fight obi-wan at
full strength vader doesn't want to
defeat this obi-wan kenobi who hasn't
been a jedi in 10 years he wants to beat
the jedi master the person that trained
him the person that he blames for
everything happening he wants to beat
him as he was he wants to beat him at
full strength there's not much joy and
just crushing somebody
with that much ease because vader just
tossed him around
that could be the reason why i let him
go because he knows he's gonna go he
knows he's gonna train more he knows
qui-gon jen's probably gonna show up and
give him a good pep talk and you know
tell him some good ways of the force
whatever it may be we know obi-wan is
going to come back from this he may look
at leia and go oh my gosh he's in
trouble again because riva got her and
now i have to train now i have to be the
jedi i have to come back we know that's
gonna happen and that might be what
vader actually wants to fight him at
full strength to have that satisfaction
of knowing like yeah i killed obi-wan i
killed jedi master obi-wan not this guy
who
you know i just tossed around and
grabbed and who who didn't even attack
me simply barely defended himself with a
lightsaber that he hadn't picked up in
10 years vader doesn't want that and
that could be a reason that he actually
let him live and this could be combined
with the torture in all honesty they
could both be very very real and i i
think they both are but the third one
gets kind of deep so this third one is
kind of deep and it's kind of like moon
night here the third theory is that
anakin is actually the reason why vader
let obi-wan go it's kind of like a moon
knight situation here you got mark
spector and you got stephen grant and
got moon knight we're gonna keep it just
to vader and anakin
somewhere inside of vader i think is
still
that little boy who obi-wan trained and
it could be a scared little boy now i
think there are multiple sides of this
now anakin
could still feel somewhat of
you know empathy sympathy whatever you
want to call it towards obi-wan he could
still care about him because again it is
the person who trained him and is the
person who he called his brother they
definitely loved each other i mean we
think about that final scene with
obi-wan of course
there could still be some feelings for
obi-wan good feelings for obi-wan left
inside of anakin right vader's the the
hateful one the the fearful one the
revengeful one that's vader but maybe a
little bit of anakin came out there now
you can also flip that you can also say
that anakin might be that scared little
boy right because again think about that
last scene think about what obi-wan did
to him think about that torture that
vader was talking about that took place
on mustafar like
he his whole body
lit into flames after having his limbs
cut off and
obi-wan did that kind of with ease yes
he had the high ground yes anakin miss
schooled that day and didn't learn about
the high ground but you think about that
scene it's just a quick little boom next
thing you know he's only got one arm
left and he's trying to crawl up but he
catches on fire and obi-wan thought he
died and then he found out he didn't
but that
scars you
physically for sure as you know we saw
in the beginning of episode three but
mentally that scars you
so there could be somewhat of a
paralyzation there right that could have
caused him just to go i'm just gonna let
him go for now like am i truly ready to
kill obi-wan kenobi
that could have been going through his
head right there and he could have just
had some fear now ultimately
vader is vader and i know vader wants to
kill obi-wan kenobi yes i know that but
i'm just thinking that maybe there is a
small part that is the anakin side of
darth vader like padme said there is
still some good in him and we know that
we know there's some good in him we see
it right in future movies we see it so
maybe maybe just a tiny bit now i do
think it's probably a combination of the
three of them if anything probably the
combination of the first two one
vader was toying with him i think that's
pretty obvious because he could have
killed him very easily two vader wants
him at his full strength because is
there much fun for vader in
just beating somebody that is just so
easy probably not and there's also that
sense of pride of beating the jedi
master that trained you right i think
there's a little bit of that going on as
well so let me know what you think about
all of these theories do you think it's
one of them do you think it's a few of
them you think it's none of them let me
know in the comments down below let me
know if you have theories of your own be
sure to like the video and subscribe for
more star wars content for live updates
you can always follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
you